today is a special halloween weekender
it's a hollow weekender with rocks
hi okay first up to watch
hocus pocus you have to it's the
ultimate
movie okay in an interview with good day
new york bet
midler confirmed that a sequel with the
original sanderson sisters
and the rest of the cast is truly in
the works huge the internet exploded
when that was announced
everyone's so excited i have to say too
that it's so
fun to see a movie grow over time
with like cool factor and
cult status and this film really
defines that yeah you want a little fun
fact about hocus pocus
what bet you didn't know this you know
max dennison the main character the
guest do you know who was originally
offered to play that part who leonardo
dicaprio
this is a true story and he turned it
down to do uh what's eating gilbert
grape
oh i love stuff like that i'm full of
stuff like like useless knowledge
full of it well and what's eating
gilbert grape with such an epic
performance of his
yeah that's oscar nomination was for
that movie yes no that was like
we knew leonardo dicaprio was everything
yeah oh
i bet you know him huh i do actually i
by the way i
yes i do uh he would come around the set
of poison ivy because he was friends
with sarah gilbert
and so i've known him since i was 16
years old you
are so much cooler than ross matthews i
just want to put that out there and i
love that i know you thank you for that
no and he's i like he's just grown into
the most extraordinary human being
talent-wise and his awareness and he
really is everything
you know i mean i don't know but i'm
gonna take your word for it because i
don't know him
but you do yeah i mean we all live for
leonardo dicaprio
okay our next wreck is a book
i got that all right he has a book to
read a creepy classic do you remember
this one
it's called a dark dark room in a dark
dark room
this book scared me so much as a kid
it's a collection of scary stories and
it's still giving adults the willies
uh remember the story about the green
ribbon around the woman's neck
i made me rethink chokers for the rest
of my life i do know that book
and i do know it will give you
nightmares but for people who like scary
things that's the book for you
are you a scary movie scary book kind of
person nope i'm not at all and my
daughters watched
the witches um the other night and they
were like clawing into my back because
they were so scared yeah i can only do
about mommy dearest that's like as scary
as i can
as i can get bring me the axe i might as
well have
mgm tattooed on my backside
mayor should know the price i pay
i've never been more in love with you
than right this very moment
ah and did you know ross that i am one
of your fans
okay next halloween we're doing mommy
dearest got it kids well that's a side
tip for the weekender
and if you want to listen to something
creepy check out the haunted places
podcast
each episode you visit a different
haunted place
mansions cemeteries and hotels they've
got them all
and you'll learn the spooky backstory of
the place and take a chilling audio tour
this week they're talking about the
location
of one of pennsylvania's last witch
trials
okay i might actually listen to that
that sounds interesting and i have
another suite to eat for you
and this one comes from the little
yellow bones
yes you can find this list on our
website
every week it's the things i love and
want to share with you
and i am fully obsessed with hugh
dark chocolate this one is the vanilla
crunch bar
it's 70 cacao cacao cow
it's a dark chocolate which is really
healthy for you and the crunch is
quinoa which is not even a green it's a
protein
vanilla bean and sea salt it's num num
num num yum
and it's gone i have to tell you i eat
one bar in every sitting
cow right
oh i okay what do you think oh my god
it's good for me
just say yes please that is so good
yes i love it and if you need to burn
off some of those treats and you need
another use for that festive pumpkin
try the pumpkin workout from pop sugar
fitness trainer danielle pucenti
has put together a 10-step workout
routine that you can do with the help of
your pumpkin pal
look at all you can do with a pumpkin
come on feel the burn
pumping pumpkin it pumpkin
all right oh my gourd now where is my
wand
there it is thank you darling
[Music]
you